[موسيقى]
ارتفعت الطائره تدريجيا في رحلتها الى 28
الف قدم ولم تسجل اي انخفاض قبل انقطاع
الاتصال بها وفق بيانات ملاحيه من فلايت
رادار وقالت شبكه الروسيه ان الطائره
اختفت عن الرادار بعد 26 دقيقه من
مغادرتها وبحسب بيانات فلايت رادار فان
الاستقرار في ارتفاع الطائره اثناء سيرها
يقلل احتماليه هبوطها بسبب عطل فني او خطا
وذكر شبكه رين تي في الروسيه ان الطاقم لم
يستجب لانذاءات متعدده بعد اختفاء الطائره
عن الرادار واضافت الشبكه ان الطائره
المملوكه لقائد فاجنر سقطت بجناح واحد حسب
شهود عيان كما اكدت بيانات ملاحيه للجزيره
ان عدم تسجيل اي انخفاض في ارتفاع الطائره
المتحطمه الشمال موسكو يزيد من احتماليه
سقوطها بسبب مؤثر خارجي